denn überhaupt hier ist ein kaktus hallo
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video zu aller
erst hier halt ein bisschen also ich
habe hier schon sehr viel leer geräumt
weil ich gleich umziehen in eine neue
wohnung aber dazu sage ich am ende des
videos was wir reden jetzt erstmal mit
dem clever bot ich hab mir schon so ein
bisschen mit dem clever bot geschrieben
und zwar am ersten zwölfter schon was
vor nein der motivation geladene antwort
kennst du den luca - shop.de
den kennt er den solltest du 112 mal
besuchen wieso weil da mein neuer merge
dropped erster zwölfter nokia shop de
es wird leute geben die dunkeln leuchten
so viel leiser chat ziel des heutigen
videos ist es herauszufinden ob der
clever wort mit mir ein 24 stunden video
drehen würde deswegen fragen wir ihnen
hier erstmal kennst du den 24 stunden
trend so mal schauen ob er welche den
von youtube okay was sagt er darauf
where are you on youtube
warum reden wir denn jetzt in englisch
kannst du auch deutsch sprechen lieber
clever wort ja ich spreche deutsch okay
das ist sehr schön wir befinden uns auf
dem kanal von leon macht er sagen wir
jetzt einfach mal ich weiß warum fragst
du mich dann an da oben noch der clever
bord hat glaube ich keine richtige
ahnung was dieser 24 stunden trend mit
diesen videos und so ist deswegen
erklären wir ihnen das jetzt hier vor
einigen monaten gab es in amerika den
trend sich 24 stunden in verschiedenen
geschäftsziel geschäften aufzuhalten und
dieses zu filmen
dann haben deutsche youtuber diesen
trend profitiert und machen damit viele
klicks
leider kann ich nicht mehr schreiben ich
mach mal dass dahinter einfach weg und
setzten punkt punkt punkt dahinter mal
schauen was der klammer wird darauf von
mir drei bis vier stunden waren schon
mal da alles klar
clever bot vier stunden videos lieber
klare worte ich hab dir da gerade extra
alles groß erklärt was ist worum es
dabei hat das ist das ist das ist das
ist typisch trevor bot wenig erklärt
neben der juc den juckt es mich zu ihr
habt übrigens zu beginn des videos
richtig gehört ich zum deswegen seht ihr
das einzige was ihr in diesem zimmer
noch steht es der kaktus die denn
überhaupt hier ist ein kaktus ich mach
das nicht so wie andere youtuber und
sage so zehntausendfach ja ich ziehe
jetzt um und film euch dann wie ich das
ganze einrichte wie die leute das im u
vormachen also das ist schon alle zwei
drei monate in der mache derzeit nicht
öffentlich gemacht aber ab morgen sind
die ersten videos aus meiner neuen busse
ich habe versucht geschirr einzupacken
und habe mich dabei über geräts was man
auf wir fragen den clever wird jetzt
erst mal machst du auch youtube-videos
ich meine vielleicht finden wir dadurch
heraus ob er wirklich auf der plattform
aktiv ist vielleicht vielleicht auch
nicht kannst du mir entweder positiv
oder negativ antworten lieber clever bot
ist das möglich ja kann ich
machst du videos und darum schreibt er
wie jetzt weißt du nicht mehr was videos
sind wir gehen mal einfach davon aus
dass der clever bot weiß was videos sind
und weiß wie man das macht hättest du
lust mal mit mir 1 4
und 20 alter mal mit mir ein
viele wörter mit drei buchstaben
hintereinander wie bekomme ich auch so
was ich habe heute einfach noch nichts
gegessen dazu will ich nochmal norovirus
aus kuriere und sinnfällig 24 stunden
video aufzunehmen die bei clever bot das
wäre so cool
welches spiel möchtest du denn spielen
kein ich schreib einfach real life real
life sich so warst was passiert wenn man
bei google wirst du warst ein geht hier
kommt komplette scheiße bei google und
vor allem auch etwas wo warst du gehst
dann ich war bei dir du warst nicht da
hey leute was los mit euch hauptsache
bild von dani hey warum wollen wir einen
24 stunden video aufnehmen ja was für
eins oder klappt wird es mit dabei
einfach nur wie ich mit dir chile
fragezeichen ich verstehe nicht das ist
mal was ganz neues
ich bin für 24 stunden bei dir und ich
filme das kommt vom punkt da versagt der
cover das tust du ich habe hunger was
hältst du von diesem 24 stunden videos
fragezeichen vieles und was als wenn
vieles ist der größte scheiß der welt
die leute begehen straftaten in ihren
videos und die leute feiern dass ich
verstehe es nicht was wir marschieren
apa/red sich dabei denken so das ist
doch das typische beispiel von klicks
ist uns viel wichtiger als alles andere
dass da leute arbeiten und die
schwimmbäder saubermachen oder die
kinosommer mal juckt nicht wir klauen
auch noch maciej kommen clever pardon
feierst du das überhaupt warum fährst du
das alter was soll das man weil ich dir
vertraut ja dann solltest du es nicht
feiern dann solltest du es aber
eigentlich nicht gut finden punkt.de
appelliert mal so ein bisschen an die
was soll ich nicht behaupten dass zu
feiern ich verfluche dich doch gar nicht
das bringt hier gerade gar nichts
irgendwie also wir sind mittlerweile
bei dem punkt angelangt dass wir wissen
dass der clever bot mit mir ein 24
stunden video aufnehmen will wann wollen
wir unser 24 stunden videoaufnahmen
lieber clever bot in der stunde ich
treffe ich form einer aok an leute das
was ihr vom video der klemme bot mir
abgeschrieben ich soll in der stunde bei
ihm von der arbeit sein das heißt um
20.30 ich werde jetzt hin dösen mit dem
24 stunden wieder aufnehmen dann 700 24
stunden weder übrigens sorry falls das
video hier komplett bescheuert war aber
ich habe immer noch norovirus bin halt
krank habt total im stress mit dem umzug
bin unter hungert und hatte heute noch
uni und muss gleich noch umziehen also
ich wollte halt nur weil gestern nichts
kamen habe ich jetzt heute noch
irgendwas aufgenommen hier in einem
leeren zimmer also ich hoffe es hat euch
vielleicht trotzdem gefallen würde mich
freuen
ich gehe zum clever wort
[Musik]